On February 22nd Sony will release the
PlayStation Vita its new portable video
gaming system in the United States for
right now we've got our Japanese launch
unit here which came out in December and
we're going to tell you all about it now
unless you are the kind of hardcore
gamer that buys every single video
gaming system or one of the last
remaining members of the tribe of sony
fanboys you may be asking why do I need
a PlayStation Vita I've already got my
iPhone 4 and my Kindle Fire and all
kinds of other things that do other
things besides playing video games
well Sony's answer is PlayStation Vita
only does games but it does gaming right
now if you really wanted to play Angry
Birds on the PlayStation Vita I guess
you could it's got a touchscreen it's
got motion controls just like your
smartphone but it also has what gamers
want it has buttons it has a d-pad it
has twin analog sticks
it's even got a rear touchpad for even
more control options and it's got tons
of horsepower under the hood I mean the
games look like mini PlayStation 3 games
and they're all displayed on a very
large oh le d-- screen which is so
bright and so gorgeous that it makes
your iphone 4 display cry itself to
sleep at night but graphics are really
not the most important thing for
portable gaming system what's important
is ease of use and we found that Vita is
actually really great for gaming on the
go I mean it's got about 4 to 5 hours of
battery life which is ok it's about with
the Nintendo 3ds gets but with the Vita
you know you can pop it into sleep mode
and then wait a couple of days and come
back and you've still got plenty of
juice for gaming and that's really
important Vita has a very intuitive user
interface you hit the PlayStation button
and you can scroll through all of the
different apps that are using you can
multitask you can download games while
you're doing other things now is there a
catch of course there's a catch
PlayStation Vita costs $300 for the 3G
enabled version and 250 dollars for the
Wi-Fi only version but it requires you
to buy a separate memory card if you
want to do basically anything a lot of
games even the ones that come on
cartridges like Uncharted golden
this will not even boot up if you don't
have a memory card so do you pop in one
of your extra SD cards or a memory stick
Pro duo no absolutely not PlayStation
Vita has its own separate memory card
systems that's only used for PlayStation
Vita and they cost about twice as much
as comparable sizes of SD cards and
memory sticks if you want a four
gigabyte card it's gonna cost you twenty
dollars if you want the biggest card
which is 32 gigabytes you're going to be
paying $100 for it
now once you've laid out this extra
hundred bucks for a 32 gigabyte stick
you can download every game in the Vitas
library including ones that are
otherwise available on cartridges now
this is a really big deal you don't have
to carry around a baggie full of games
anymore if you don't want to out of the
box the Vita has a variety of built-in
apps the coolest one is called NIR and
what this does is lets you see everyone
in your immediate area who's also
playing a PlayStation Vita you can see
what games they're playing and you can
add them to your friends list if you
want to now you can also put your photos
your music your movies onto the
PlayStation Vita but let's face it are
you really gonna be using this thing to
browse your family album no you're gonna
be playing Uncharted PlayStation Vita is
all about video gaming and ultimately
the quality of the games is going to be
what determines the success or the
failure of this piece of hardware